You know, Andy, coming into this new year
there's lots of things I'd
like to leave behind in 2020.
I agree, I mean, it has been a rough year.
If only we could just flush it all away.
Ah, interesting brand
conscious word choice, Andy.
'Cause lucky for us
Cottonelle is giving
people the opportunity
to flush away something they
wanna leave behind in 2020
with their new sweepstakes
the Refreshingly Clean Slate.
What a great way to start 2021 fresh.
Right again, Andy.
Everyone who participates
will have a chance to win
up to $21,000 for their own
personal clean slate (laughs)
And Cottonelle will be
donating $20.21 to United Way
for every entry up to $1
million dollar donation.
It's a chance to win money
and to help a good cause.
We should enter.
Good idea, Andy.
All contestants have to do
is write one thing from 2020
they wanna leave behind on
a square of toilet paper,
snap a picture of it, share
it on Instagram or Twitter,
and explain why you're leaving it behind
and what you're looking forward to.
Make sure to tag Cottonelle
and use the #RefreshinglyCleanSlate
and #Sweepstakes for a chance to win.
I actually already have something
I wanna leave behind in 2020
written on a square of toilet paper.
Wow, what a coincidence, me too!
Hey, let's show them at the same time
on three, huh?
One, two,
COVID.
Conan.
Andy, what the hell?
(laughs) Whoa, I won.
I guess Conan O'Brien
was the right answer.
Andy, you're fired.
Great, all thanks to Cottonelle.
Enter Cottonelle's Refreshingly
Clean Slate sweepstakes
and you might get to flush
away 2020 just like me.
(laughs) Cha-ching.